the gang is naturally the community you
know what i'm saying and um
you know everybody from the gang since
the beginning of time is not a [ __ ]
killer you know what i'm saying or even
not people that commit crimes like i got
big homies that
my whole entire life knowing them they
had jobs and they was family men but you
know they was a part of the community
and they showed they support
which is necessary
yummy and helping like younger homies
find their way you know what i'm saying
now
if
if everybody from the area just decided
to man [ __ ] this [ __ ] i ain't talking to
nobody i ain't dealing with where does
that leave the people that come next you
know what i'm saying it
so it's like a real thin line but i
definitely wouldn't tell nobody to go
kill nobody or go do no [ __ ] like that
or commit no crimes i would say like all
right if that's where you're from
you know represent where you're from but
you don't have to be a [ __ ] gang
banger you could be a doctor a lawyer a
fireman a [ __ ] cop if you want to you
know what i'm saying but
you know i wouldn't just say uh
like [ __ ] the hood like that you know
i'm saying